ladies and gentlemen please welcome
Academy Award winner Nicole Kidman
and the first Oscar of the night goes to
a man who first came to prominence in a
television show playing an emergency
room doctor or it goes to a man who
received an Oscar for his flamboyant
performance in kiss of the Spider Woman
or it goes to a man who was one half of
one of the screens most
precedent-setting couples or it goes to
a famous heartthrob who played a
decidedly unromantic policeman or it
goes to a man whose Cinderella man had
in his corner fight after fight these
are all supporting roles but in my
opinion they are all leading men and the
nominees for Best Supporting Actor are
George Clooney in Syriana Matt Dillon in
crash
Paul Giamatti in Cinderella man
Jake Gyllenhaal and Brokeback Mountain
William Hurt in a history of violence
and the Oscar goes to and the Oscar goes
to George Clooney in Syriana this is the
first Academy Award and third nomination
tonight for George Clooney this is the
first time a nominee in the
is also nominated in an acting category
for another film
Wow Wow all right so I'm not winning
director it's funny thing about winning
an Academy Award this will always be
sort of synonymous with your name from
here on in it'll be Oscar winner George
Clooney and sexiest man alive 1997
Batman died today in a freak accident of
a listen I don't quite know how you
compare art I just you look at these
performances this year of these actors
and unless we all did the same roll
everybody put on a bat suit well I'll
try that unless we all did the same role
I don't know how you compare it
they are stellar performances and
wonderful work and I'm honored truly
honored to be up there and finally I
would say that you know we are a little
bit out of touch in in Hollywood every
once in a while I think it's probably
good thing
we're the ones who talk about AIDS when
it was just being whispered and we
talked about civil rights when it wasn't
really popular and we you know we we
bring up subjects we were the ones this
is this Academy this group of people
gave Hattie McDaniel an Oscar in 1939
when blacks were still sitting in the
backs of theaters I'm proud to be a part
of this Academy proud to be part as a
community and proud to be out of touch
and I thank you so much for this
you